so here's what I have done and I really
like this I've seen I've seen three
different solutions this morning I
including my own one and they're all
different which is kind of the point I
would say to Russell before when you get
to an answer at the end I hope you've
had that feeling sometimes VI I'm not
sure if this is right or not and
sometimes I'm nearby
and you should get to check you know
with me sometimes the questions out of a
textbook so you're like oh okay I'll
just check and see if the answer is
agrees but then that raises a bigger
question the wider question of well how
did the textbook writers know like how
to had a winner when we set an exam but
our answer is the right answer and the
idea is that like I said to you before
okay this gives us another way into a
question right don't have to point to
find the points of intersection don't
have to use calculus but when we want to
confirm whether we got it right or not
well we go and find the plates and see
if they agree we go and use calculus and
we see if we can confirm the result from
another angle okay so I'm going to show
you one I'm gonna ask you another one
and then it's probably enough and maybe
your answer is different again if ours
is agree then thumbs up so I've got this
line this parabola so this you can see
is like a generalized version of this
guy you see that it's like it's this
line but I can move it up or down and
what I want to do presumably I want to
move it from my diagram my sketchy sort
of thing before I guess I want to move
it down right because if I move it up
it's not going to become a teacher right
it's just going to keep on intersecting
but if I move it down if I get to the
right point it'll look like that yeah
it's like tada tangent okay so if it is
attention then when they intersect it
should have one and only one point of
intersection okay so I've just called a
gamma I would have normally called an
alpha but I sort of use that already so
let's use this as a starting point okay
now just like before I can solve these
simultaneously to find this point of
intersection okay and also just like
before to use my polynomial technique on
this thing I don't want to say it as one
polynomial equals another polynomial I
want to phrase it as a single polynomial
equal to zero because then I can use all
this fancy knowledge I have that sum and
product of original back so I'm just
going to rearrange and collect like
terms so when I get everything on one
side there's only a single x squared
term if I subtract 2x
both sides I end up with that and what's
my constant term look like it's going to
be minus B minus 8 sad all right because
I have to subtract this B from both
sides okay so this is the thing I'm
dealing with I can see what my first
coefficient is I can see what my second
coefficient is you notice I'm not
calling them a and B and C can you G
notice why right like I've said before
these values get used are these
predicates used so often you just have
to be careful don't trip over yourself
and say that my my B's
not B that's a bad plus tough to go down
so now what can I do with this right
well this is my quadratic and I know
it's got two roots that are both at the
same point or I could say it has a
double root right so I can therefore say
this sum of roots is not alpha cos beta
it's a gamma plus gamma what is the
summer fruits have a look at the
quadratic I created it's just going to
be minus negative 4 on 1 which is 4
which is actually the same results
before okay so this tells me that gamma
is 2 so I have an x coordinate that's
great how am I going to get to order y
coordinate well I can see that like I'll
have to be on time and that's going to
be from the product of roots do you see
that I use this number in the sum of
roots and we use this one in the product
of roots so I can say that gamma times
gamma is equal to C on a yet you agree
with that so unit so that's minus B
minus 8 except I already know what gamma
is so gamma squared will be 4 like so
add 8 to both sides
excuse me 12 and that gives me a value
for B that make sense
quick sense check does that confirm what
I sort of intuited when I had a look at
my diagram it does right remember I said
oh I've got to move this guy down well B
equals negative 12 pushes this guy down
12 units so thumbs up okay now like I
said like I laid at the point this is
not the only way you could do it so Eric
you started your question a whole
all different way what did you do okay
pause there let's just figure out what
Eric just said because that went by very
quickly we are solving it by the way the
same way we get the same answer but what
he's doing is he's using part a and B
which is a smart way to go and say if
this really is at ages that a and B are
no longer two different points they are
the same point okay so he's basically
saying a which is this equals B which is
that does that make sense
which is perfectly jim it right keep
going yep okay pause there
so what Eric is done is he's got he's
had to start the same way that we have
right so he's created the same quadratic
he's gone to here but then he said look
if these two things are the same then
this thing has to be a perfect square
why is that it's not a perfect square
when you factorize you'll get something
like this right I don't know here's a
here's something which is not a perfect
square okay
it's not perfect where you can still
factorize you get two roots to it but if
you want both of the roots to be the
same both the answers to be same you
have to have something like like this
right well I call it gamma you have to
have something like that a perfect
square see that quadratic has degree 2
but only one solution right so therefore
from here he said the only way this is a
perfect square look at it carefully is
if like how would you complete the
square what is this thing what is the
constant I'm supposed to be if this is
going to be a perfect square look at it
it has to be 4 where do you get 4 from
plus 4 by the way where do your four
front yeah yeah you're think right
yeah I'm not calling it V right take
this coefficient just like you normally
do when you're completing the square you
have and then you square you have and
square so that means this thing is
really supposed to be this do you agree
well that tells you that - Pete excuse
me - B - eight has to be 4 - b - 8 has
to be 4
does that look familiar why of course we
end up with the same answer ok but a
nice different way of going about it
different sort of logic but it's the
same idea they make sense
so our pause there let me reword - the
first thing I said with this question
you could have done all of this question
without any of these fancy polynomial
sums in parts of reason or like an
effect you could have just brute force
coordinate geometry your way through it
find the point of intersection and then
off you go okay however when you start
tackling these questions you will
encounter questions where the brute
force of your all coordinate geometry
techniques just don't cut it anymore you
won't be able to find there'll be too
many variables
there will be proteome rules you just
you can't actually in this case you can
find these points of intersection just
using like your $10 right but if I make
some more weird things in here you can't
and then what do you do well now you
know how to use these tools okay